some of the changes since 9/11 have been
positive I mean an enormous amount of
money has been thrown at the
intelligence community so you went from
a period in the 90s where the peace
dividend after the Cold War was in many
cases taken at the expense of the
intelligence community and there wasn't
much hiring going on and a lot of early
retirements are being forced and there
weren't very many investments and place
had really kind of hollowed out after
9/11 massive amounts of money were
thrown in everybody went on a huge
hiring sprees and what you I mean I
don't live inside the community but
touring it and bumping up against it
what I my impression is that immediately
after 9/11 you had an extraordinarily
talented group of young people volunteer
to go in an intelligence video probably
the best generation of public servants
and went into the government you know
since the 60s people were motivated they
were smart they were well-educated and
they were committed after 9/11 and then
but they went into the system system we
really don't know how to absorb them and
a lot of them bounced out a lot of
people became disillusioned there
weren't good senior programs or officers
available to mentor them and so I think
that sort of wave of young people as has
been atrophied and and maybe not sort of
brought up the way the way you would
when in the meanwhile one of their
experiences when all these really great
people went in was that the whole system
kept being reorganized and then
reorganized again and the way the
agencies were all moving around and so I
think the sense you have from inside is
that there's still a lot of confusion
about what is a career in intelligence I
mean how do you actually have a useful
and successful and interesting career as
a as an operative
I mean analysts the you know there's
millions of analysts running around but
as to the actual collection of
intelligence which was what the problem
seem to be running up to 911 I don't
think the system is is I don't think the
system is fixed at all I think it's
still a mess private firms I think
that's I think that's plain I think it's
I don't think that private contractors
ought to be acting on the battlefield as
sort of proxies for or allies of the US
military I think private contracting for
logistics and for support and for
technology and maybe for some analysis
can be part of a governmental system but
to have private contractors in the field
carrying out the the sort of statecraft
of war or shadowy intelligence warlike
activity paramilitary or collection
activity I think is a mistake hard to
tell I mean you know he's a he's a
professional who I think was welcomed
there when he was appointed because the
turmoil of the previous regime had been
pretty considerable he was a known
quantity he was known to be sort of a
friend of the CIA wasn't there to tear
it down or kind of reinvent it the way
some other directors had had come in
wanting to do but the basic problem that
that he faces and that the agency faces
is that they basically been reorganized
out of their prestige and to some extent
reorganized out of their parts of their
mission and you know they've lost their
place at the table their place at the
table with the White House is now taken
by the Director of National Intelligence
the new sort of czar of all the
intelligence agencies and that means the
CIA is adjusting to a completely
different world in which it does know it
no longer has direct contact with the
President nighted States every morning
that's what made the CIA the source of
all this mystique in our political
culture was that you know every morning
first thing 6:30 or 7:00 a.m. the
president united states sits down with
the director of the CIA or his
designated briefer and they talked about
the world
and when the president wants something
done off the books he turns to the CIA
and he says directly you know I want to
I want to raid Cuba or I want to foment
dissent in this country or that and that
relationship of the President and the
CIA is broken it just doesn't exist
anymore the CIA is now more like the FBI
it works in one step removed it has a
mission to go out into the world and
steal secrets and occasionally go out in
the world and blow up bridges but it's
doing that almost as a kind of separate
like a like a like a Federal Reserve
that those monetary policy that they're
divorced from from policy and
decision-making or there's an
intermediary in the DEA and not DNI and
I think Hayden has not been able to
quite resolve how this reorganization
will play out in the in the life of the
institution well there's a very
beautiful bait within the US Army and
the military continuing now and I'm
still I'm doing some work on this now
and you know the the strain everyone
agrees there's an enormous strain the
question is that are the questions that
are debated are what are the strategic
consequences of this strain and on the
one hand you have those like Casey or
certain Colonels and others who would
emphasize the loss of combat capability
the potential for a surprise elsewhere
in the world that the United States
can't respond to and and the general
sort of inability of the United States
to say pivot from Iraq where things may
be going better to Afghanistan where
things are clearly going worse because
there just is no there's no elasticity
in the in the system anymore the
resources are all on the in the field so
that's one side the other side
emphasizes as gates did in a speech a
couple of weeks ago look we have armies
to win the wars that we're in
you know I would rather break an army
winning the war that we have to win than
worry about some future scenario nobody
the stuff somebody was arguing with than
the other day says you know nobody
worried during World War two that we
were going to break the army and
overemphasize figuring out how to beat
Nazi Germany and then we were going to
miss Vietnam because we hadn't prepared
for a counter insurgency you know no you
you that's what you have armies for is
to go all-out to achieve the objectives
you need to achieve now so then that
depends on whether you believe finishing
in Iraq with every brigade available is
really in the national interest and so
in the end these arguments about strain
and breaking the army they're a kind of
coded argument about whether Iraq is
still worthwhile well I think the hunch
still important for a lot of reasons you
know starting with justice the fact that
he's you know at large and and has more
or less accepted responsibility for the
attacks and no one's ever bothered to
chase him down but more sort of relevant
to the current scene this we talked
before about the 20 years of continuous
leadership the ability to deliver
messages to followers to define the
narrative of the war that he believes
he's leading to identify targets to name
countries he still matters he doesn't
matter the way he did in 1999 but taking
him off the airwaves and forcing
al-qaeda to deal for the first time in
20 years with the succession crisis
probably from the point of view of
al-qaeda's adversaries would be a good
objective so I think there are lots of
reasons why the hunt for him still
matters yes to what al-qaeda's
capability is this year I think all you
can really do is look at what the system
is reporting by way of kind of threat
reporting on the one hand and then what
all the open source evidence from the
last three or four years tells you about
their capability and I think that in
summary what it tells you is that they
still have the intent to carry out what
you might think of as sort of medium
sized
attacks against airplanes against subway
systems against embassies military bases
they have the capability to plan sort of
six to nine month fairly complicated
fairly ambitious plans like the one
that's on trial in London involving the
attempt to blow up planes over the
Atlantic in August of 2006 the one that
led to us not being able to carry our
toothpaste aboard airplanes that was
their most ambitious plot since 9/11 it
was meant to be the fifth anniversary
plot was meant to take down five to ten
planes if it had succeeded you'd have
we'd be living in a different world
there'd be 600 or more dead Americans
and Brits lying in the Atlantic Ocean
we'd probably be occupying the federally
administered tribal areas and engaged in
a very vicious counterinsurgency
campaign but that's been their most
ambitious plot since and it's it's a
couple of orders of magnitude short of
9/11 so I think they'll probably I mean
bin Laden keeps an eye on Qaeda keeps an
eye on the calendar they know this is an
election season I think he'll probably
want to do something in 2004 what we can
see in retrospect is that he didn't have
the capability to do anything other than
a media event but he appeared like an
apparition on the weekend before the
election and delivered this message to
the American people John Kerry still
believes to this day it was a factor in
his defeat in a close election so at a
minimum I expect them to attempt media
events but if they have capability
they'll probably use it during the fall
season yeah